hello everyone if there was someone who
knew the future exactly then he would be
the richest man on earth
all he has to do is walk into a casino
place all the right beds and watch out
with all the money he needs
unfortunately such a person does not
exist and therefore we need to study
profit inequalities
profit and inequalities tell you what to
do in a casino when you do not have
knowledge of the future
the setting is the following suppose you
have n equals to five treasure boxes
and you do not know how much treasure is
inside each box or how much reward is
inside each box but having dealt with
pressure boxes all your life you know
for each Bots a distribution such that
the actual amount of pressure is sampled
for the from this distribution for
example for the first Parts you may know
that the actual amount of pressure
inside is uniform between three and five
for the second one you may know it's
uniform between one and nine and so on
for the remaining boxes
now you're only allowed to take one of
these boxes and you want to take as much
reward as possible what do you do
well the answer is simple you open all
the boxes you look at what's inside and
you pick the Bots with the largest
reward
this is what I will call an offline
solution it is always the optimal
solution you take all the boxes and you
see the best for you and you take that
and I want to contrast this with an
online solution
in the online solution you go to the
first Parts you open it and now you need
to make a decision you see it has four
units of reward you need to decide
whether you want to take these four
units of reward in which case the game
is over you don't see what is in the
other boxes or you can skip these four
units of robot forever and look at the
next box
so suppose you decide to step
then you open the second box you see it
has seven units of reward now again you
have to make a decision do you take
these seven units of reward and then you
don't see any of the remaining boxes or
you skip them and then you look at the
third box and so on
so suppose you actually take these seven
units of reward The Game Stops you walk
away with seven and then this is your
online solution now
because the offline solution is always
the best it is always also larger than
the online solution and a profit
inequality is just the ratio between the
best offline solution and the best
online solution this is always larger
than one
and the field of profit inequalities
deals with the following question given
a set of feasibility constraints a
feasibility constraint is just a set of
subsets of boxes that you're allowed to
date so in this example the feasibility
constraint would be the set of all
Singleton sets of watches because you're
only allowed to take one box you may
consider more General feasibility
constraints where say you're all you're
allowed to take any set of size at most
three of boxes and then the feasibility
constraints will be different but for
any given set of feasibility constraints
you can define a profit inequality which
is the ratio of the best offline
solution to the best online solution and
it's always at least one
the set of feasibility constraints that
we are interested in are those that can
be written as an interception of Q
metroids where Q is a parameter
if you don't know what a Metroid is
trust me even I didn't know what a
Metroid is before this paper so it's
okay to not know it we will Define it
when we need it but it's a well-defined
notion it's a central problem that we
want profit and quality Bonds on
a lot of work has been done on it and
for example we know that if you have an
intercession of two metroids then the
profit inequality is upper bounded by E
times two plus one here e is
approximately 2.7 it is the base of the
natural logarithm and
the way I want you to think of this
result is that it is a new algorithm it
shows that offline over online is at
most this which means it basically gives
you a new online algorithm that gets a
large chunk of the offline reward
okay
if you restrict this to the special case
of partition mat rights then you can get
even better algorithms very recently it
was shown
that for partition metroids which are a
special case of all metroids you have an
algorithm that gets an even larger chart
it shapes up a factor of feed that's a
two plus one fraction of the offline
Revenue
again if you do not know what is a
partition Metroid neither do I it
doesn't matter right now okay these are
the upper bounds
we also have a lower bound
we know that for partition metroids The
Profit inequality which is the ratio of
offline over online is always at least
root 2. and if the upper bounds were
algorithms this lower bound is an
impossibility result it shows that
regardless of what your online algorithm
does
it can never get more than a one over
root two fraction of the offline reward
I'm using reward and revenue
interchangeably they are basically the
same terms for us and
this is the best lower bound we know
root Cube the best upper bound we know
is two plus one and therefore there's a
gap of root two versus two between the
best upper bar and the best lower bound
and our work tries to make progress on
this Gap we show a better lower bar
instead of showing Q to the one half we
show a better lower amount of Q to the
one half plus one over lot Q which again
also holds for partition metroids
this is our main result we show that if
you have an intersection of cube
partition metroids then your profit
inequality is at least Q to the half
plus one over lot Q
now
you may complain that this improvement
over Q to the half is relatively minor
and that is a true complaint but
the the real contribution of this result
is it gives us the right direction to
hunt for we had a gap between root q and
Q that both of them to be honest are
very natural solutions for the profit
and quality we did not know which one
but with this new lower bound we now
know the direction we have to look in we
know that we should go for better lower
bounds first and see how far we can push
them and then maybe try to get the right
answer from the other side
so the quantitative contribution is this
new lower bound the qualitative
contribution is the right direction but
it doesn't solve the problem exactly so
there's still a gap between Q to the
half plus one over log lot Q which is
what we get versus order Q which is the
best upper bound and closing the scrap
is not it's a great question that we
leave open
this is the main result next I will
overview the proof of this result and
our proof follows the framework given by
KW 12.
in this framework
there is a parameter B
there are P to the P groups of boxes
shown as follows each group has P boxes
so p is 5 here
and each box has unit reward with
probability one over P so you get one
unit of reward and with the remaining
probability the Bots is empty and you
get zero reward
okay
this is the system the feasibility
constraints only allow you to pick boxes
from one of these groups if you want you
can take all five of these boxes that is
valid you can take this Bots this Bots
and this Bots because they are in the
same group that is also valid but you
cannot for example take this Bots with
this Bots because these two lie in
different groups and that is not allowed
these are the feasibility constraints
and I claim that with these constraints
The Profit inequality is at least p why
is that
consider the best offline solution
the best offline solution opens all the
boxes each Bots is one with probability
one over p
which means a group of P boxes is all
once with probability at least one over
P to the p
and because there are P to the P groups
of what says in expectation there is at
least one group that has all the Bots is
equal to one the offline solution will
simply fit this group and it will get a
reward of P
okay now let us look at the best online
solution
the online solution cannot see the boxes
in the future and for
buyer construction all these boxes are
symmetric so to the online solution all
of these boxes look the same and
therefore as soon as this online
solution fits one of the boxes it gets
locked into the group of that box and it
cannot pick anything outside that group
but as soon as you're locked inside a
group you only have P boxes each with an
expected reward of one over p and
therefore your expected reward is only a
constant
so the reward of the offline algorithm
is Omega p the reward of the online
algorithm is a constant the
multiplicative gap which is the profit
inequality is therefore at least T and
this is the framework of kw12 for
showing profit and equality lower bounds
the only thing missing from this
framework is we haven't actually talked
about metroids
we have to show that this set of
feasibility constraints where you're
only allowed to pick botches from one of
the groups can actually be written as an
interception of some metroids
and this will give us new lower bonds as
an example suppose you can write this
set of feasibility constraint as an
intersection of Q equals to P Squared
Matrix then with Q equals to P Squared
metroids you're able to get a profit and
quality of P which is root Cube and
therefore you're able to show a lower
part of root Q on the profit inequality
similarly hypothetically speaking if you
were able to write this set of
feasibility constraints as an
interception of Q equals to payment P
net rights then with Q equals to P
metroids you have a profit and quality
of P which is again or Omega P which is
again Omega 2 and therefore you get a
lower bound of Omega Cube okay so the
fewer metroids you need to write this
feasibility uh constraints is the better
lower bounds you get on the original
question and what we actually show
is we are able to write this feasibility
constraint as an intersection of Q which
is slightly sub quadratic many Partition
metroids p to the 2 minus one over Lot B
partition metroids and this means that
with Q equals P to the two minus one
over lot P many metroids you get a
profit inequality of p and if you write
p in terms of U you get Q to the half
plus one over lord lot q and that is our
main result
okay
so this is what we have to do now we
have to write this feasibility
constraint which only allows you to pick
boxes from one of the groups as an
intersection of Q equals P to the 2
minus 1 over dot lot P partition made
price and now we really need to Define
partition metroids so let me take you on
a trip to India and Define partition
Matrix
so
you are in India and you see amazing
food everywhere
but you're only one person you can only
eat that much so what you decide to do
is you decide that you will take one
food item from each Indian state
and as soon as you made this decision
you're now working with Partition
metroids you have the universe of all
amazing food items in India they are
partitioned by state into various parts
and you restrict yourself to taking one
item from each state in terms of boxes
you have this universe of P times P to
the P bosses
for each meteorite you can partition
this universe into many parts and you
restrict yourself to only take items
from different parts equivalently you
only take at most one item from each
part
okay this is for one minute right we
have an intersection of cumate right so
we have few different partitions and
whatever set we take must lie in
different parts each pair of elements in
the set much light must lie in different
parts in each of the two partitions okay
this is what we have to do
and we have to show that there is a way
to get two different partitions such
that any set of D boxes
that are is in one group which means it
is feasible if and only if this set B
lies in all the main products which
means it is in different parts in all
the made words okay
this is an equivalence so we will show
each Direction separately let us focus
on the forward Direction let us show
that if your set of P boxes set B of
boxes is in one group then it lies in
all the metroids and for this I claim
that it is sufficient to have all your
metroids go in a cycle what does that
mean
we say a Metroid goes in a cycle if for
any group let's say you voters on this
group and you take the lowest element
the lowest as in the bottom most element
of this group
if this lowest element is in the second
part then and you start doing plot wise
then the next one is in the third part
the one after that is in the fourth part
the one after that is in the fifth part
and so on
similarly for this group
the lowest element or the bottom most
element is in the fifth part so the one
after that is in part one the one after
that is in part two and so on
these metroids that go in a cycle ensure
that any set B of bots is in one group
are definitely in all the metroids why
if you pick any set of boxes inside a
group because they are in the same group
they definitely belong to a different
part of each made product and by
definition because you're picking only
one item from different parts of Metroid
you are inside the Metroid this holds
for all the metroids and this finishes
the forward Direction
okay
in fact
having metroids that always go in a
cycle actually gives us a very clean
representation of these metroids suppose
I want to represent a Metroid that
always goes in a cycle then all I have
to do is I have to write a sequence of P
to the P numbers one for each group
and the number for Rook one is just the
part that the bottom most or the lowest
element of through lies in so we said
that the lowest element of group one
lies in the second part so we are two
for that here it lies in the fifth part
we write five for that and so on until
you eventually write one for the last
group and this sequence numbers uniquely
defines the first Metroid
you can do this for all the metroids in
your system and then you can Define your
system of pure metroids as a nice Vector
where the columns represent metroids the
as a nice Matrix where the columns
represent metroids the groups uh the
rows represent the groups which I will
also call vectors these are all vectors
and each coordinate uh decides um
whether the lowest item in that group
lies in which part of the matron
okay so this is now our system it's
defined by a matrix which has where the
rows are vectors and the problems are
metroids and now in this reformulation
let us see what happens to the backward
direction that we still haven't shown
for the backwards direction we have to
show that
we will show it in the converse so we
have to show if you have a set of boxes
that do not lie in one group let's say
you have two boxes this one and this one
that lie in different groups then there
is a Metroid such that both of these
belong to the same part in that Metroid
so for here here in the first Metroid
both of these will on to the same part
three and we're done
okay so what does this translate to when
you look at your metroids as these
sequences
the answer is the part of this Metroid
this uh this Bots this Bots is the first
one from the bottom most element so it
is two plus one this box is the second
one from the bottom most element it is
one plus two and these Bots will be in
the same part if and only if the bottom
most element here and the bottom most
element here differ by one
so you want two and one these two two
differ by one and then you ensure that
these two are in the same part
this was for these two specific boxes in
the general case to prohibit any Bots
from here and any Bots from here from
being selected together you have to make
sure that in this row
um
which is corresponding to the first
group and in this row it just
corresponding to this last group
and for every element in P there is
always a column such that the difference
is equal to that element
okay for example if i p is five suppose
I pick 3 then there should be a column
here such that the entry here minus the
entry here is equal to three okay if
this is true then no matter what you put
here no matter what you pitch here
there'll always be one column or one
Metroid such that they lie in the same
part and that is what you want
so I will call this property the
property of covering the set P because
for any element in P you have a column
such that the difference is equal to
that element and
in this reformulation
you now have to construct a p to the P
size family of vectors because they are
P to the P groups
each
group should have P to the 2 minus 1
over lord lot P length vectors sorry uh
this family should have P to the two
minus 1 over load lot P length vectors
because the number of metroids you want
is p to the two minus one over lord lot
p
and finally you also want this family to
cover people for any two different
vectors in this family there and any
element in P there should be a column
where they differ where the difference
is exactly that element so we want the P
to the P sized P covering family of P to
the two minus one over lord lot P length
vectors
this is the family that we construct and
we construct it recursively we show two
operations both of which state an
n-sized S is the set subset of B
covering family and length vectors to an
N Prime sized S Prime covered L Prime
length family and we will start with
smaller families uh with low covering
and get larger families with larger
coverage
we have two different operations the
first one we call the size for length
boosting and
this States an end size s covering
length family to an N Square sized s
covering two length family and this is
done by taking pairs you take all the
vectors in the first family and
these vectors will form n Square Pairs
and you take all of these pairs and you
concatenate them together okay so now
your new family has n Square different
vectors they are twice as long because
they are composed by concatenation and
the claim is this new family still
covers s why is that
you take any two pairs in this family
there's at least one element in the pair
where they are different and by
definition of the original family this
difference will cover s so the new
family will also cover us
okay this is the first operation it
gives you more size
at the cost of more length but it keeps
the cover unchanged
the second operation will give you more
cover at the cost of more length and
will keep the size unchanged and this is
done by taking an element a this is an
element of P
and you take any Vector in the original
family and you append to it
a version of itself that is scaled by a
so if you started with a vector v now
you have V and appended to it is a times
V
and the number of vectors is obviously
the same because you just append each
Vector to a steel version of itself the
length is not twice and the claim is now
this family covers s Union AFS
why well the first half of the vector is
the exact same so you obviously cover s
the second half is just shared by a so
the differences are also still and if
you had some difference in s before you
have a times that now and therefore you
cover both S and A times s so you travel
s Union 8 access
now
I want you to think of this sunn a Time
says has really been twice as large as s
it may not be the case if they are not
destroyed but let us assume we are very
clever in our choice of a and this new
set is twice as large as the original
set then in the first operation you
squared the size of the family and
doubled the length the set was unchanged
in the second operation the size was
unchanged you doubled the coverage and
the length also got double okay so if
you start with a constant size constant
covering constant length family and you
want to get these parameters then you
first need to apply this operation to
get the right size
this will keep the length as a constant
and then separately you apply this
operation to get the right coverage and
this will not change the size at all
okay so for the first thing you need to
get from constant to P to the P which
means that you have to square roughly
lot P times there is an extra term of
lot P but let's ignore that you have to
square roughly lot three times
and this will also
increase the length by a factor of p and
you get P to the P size constant
covering family of roughly peel and
vectors
okay now you have the right size so now
you start increasing the cover
and each time you do this your cover
increases by two
and your length increases by the same
factor so if you increase the cover from
2 to P your length will increase by
another p and you get e to the P size P
covering family of t squared length
vectors
this is not what I claimed I claimed
something sub quadratic I'm getting P
Squared so how do I reduce it even
further to get sub quadratic
the answer is to use a result from aa20
what they show is that for any parameter
k
if you define l like this
then you can have a 2 to the L sized
k-covering L family
and uh
2 to the L size data and family of
length L vectors
okay I claim that this actually helps us
reduce the number of operations why is
that
suppose you apply this result with K
such that L which is K to the Lord lot a
is equal to P Lot B
then you get a 2 to the L which is p to
the P sized family
of P naught P length vectors that is
State covering and because state of the
Lord Lot K is p naught p k is actually P
to the one over lot T you can do the
math
so you get P to the T sized P to the one
over lord lord P
length family
okay remember earlier we had a p to the
P size constant covering P length family
and now we have a p to the B size P to
the one word Lord P government P length
family because our coverage is larger we
now need to apply the second operation a
fewer number of types and quantitatively
we need to apply it
trees many times fewer than before
before we had lot P now we have at most
lot P minus Omega Lord period Lord Lot B
many operations and because you have
fewer operations your length will not
increase by that much each time you
apply this your length increased by a
factor of two so now you have these then
if your operations which means you save
two to this in the length so your length
instead of being P Squared is now p
squared divided by 2 to the 2 to the
this number which is equal to this and
this is the claimed result
there are some details that I'm skipping
um because
this family is only promised to do
arithmetic in the
in ZK it's doing arithmetic model okay
while we want something that does
arithmetic model op but you can fix all
of these details and you can still get
the same parameters roughly P to the P
size P covering P to the two minus one
over lord lord P length family this
implies the lower bound claimed on
Metroid profit inequalities and that's
the whole presentation thank you